قالت الشرطه الاوكرانيه ان 16 قتيلا سقطوا
بينهم طفلان في حديث تحطم مروحيه في منطقه
كيا وكان رئيس الدائره العسكريه الاقليميه
في كييف قد افاد بالسقوط ضحايا في تحطم
مروحيه بالقرب من روضه اطفال ومبنى سكني
في ضاحيه بروفاري شرق العاصمه
مع وجود اطفال وموظفين من الروضه في
الحديقه الملحقه بها وانه تم اجلاؤهم
جميعا مشيرا الى توجهه سيارات الاسعاف
والشرطه ورجال الاطفاء لموقع تحطم المروحه
بعد الان خلصت مراسل الجزيره تعمل راس
ماضي لنرصد معه ابرز واخر التطورات على
الساحه الميدانيه تمر
بالفعل الحدث ابرز خلال دقائق الاخيره هو
حادث تحطم او حادث التحطم الطائره في احدى
مناطق او منطقه كيف حتى هذه اللحظه
المعلومات شحيحه باستثناء ما يصدر من بعض
التصريحات المقتضمه عن الاداره العسكريه
في الاضافه الى الشرطه الوطنيه
يقول بان طائره عموديه تابعه لخدمات
الطوارئ الحكوميه في بروفاري تحطمت بالفعل
ويتحدث عن همم مقتل قيادات في وزاره
الداخليه الحديث خلال الدقائق الاخيره
يشير الى قيادات كبيره في وزاره الداخليه
قد يكون الرجل الاول في الوزاره وفقا لم
يتم تداوله من اخبار على
المواقع الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى وكالات
الانباء العالميه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا
نستطيع الجزم بذلك لان التصريحات كما قلت
ما زالت شحيحه ما زالت مقتضى يتحدث قائد
الشرطه عن وفيات او مقتل القيادات كانوا
على متن هذه الطائره في وزاره الداخليه
ويقول بان عدد الذين قتلوا جراء هذه
الحادثه 16 شخصا
ويتحدث عن وفاه طفلين لان الطائره سقطت في
محيط حضانه او روضه للاطفال في تلك
المنطقه في ضواحي كياب ويقول بان همم يقول
بان تسعه همم تسعه اشخاص كانوا على متن
الطائره العموديه ويتحدث عن 22 جريحا
يتلقون همم او تم نقلهم الى المستشفى في
هذه الاثناء بينهم 10 اطفال ويقول بان
جميع الخدمات المتخصصه في الموقع تعمل على
ازاله الانقاذ وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه هذا
التصريح المقتضب في الحقيقه ازدهار اا صدر
عن قائد الشرطه الوطنيه خلال الدقائق
الاخيره ونحن ننتظر هذا الهواء الاداره
العسكريه في كياب اكدت هذه الحادثه وتحدثت
عن انها حادثه كبيره وفي الحقيقه بدات
تظهر بعض الصور على صفحات تيليجرام
التابعه للمواقع الاوكرانيه همم وهذه
الصور تظهر حجم
السقوط هذا هذه الطائره تظهر حجم الدمار
الذي خلفته الطائره بعد تحطمها النيران
كانت تشتعل في اجزاء كبيره
على هذا العاجل مدير الشرطه الاوكرانيه
يقول مقتل وزير الداخليه بل يؤكد اذا مقتل
وزير الداخليه بالاضافه الى مسؤولين
الكبار في الوزاره تحطم المروحيه في كيف
تامر
بالفعل هذا ما اشار اليه قائد الشرطه
الوطنيه تحدث عن قيادات في وزاره الداخليه
في الحقيقه كنت مترددا في اذاعه خبر مقتل
وزير الداخليه لانه لم يظهر بشكل رسمي
يبدو اننا ونحن نتحدث ظهر هذا الخبر وتاكد
وتتبت بشكل رسمي اذا مقتل وزير الداخليه
الاوكرانيا الذي كان عالامه هذه الطائره
بالاضافه الى عدد من معاونين من مساعدين
الحديث وفقا لشرطه كياب ولقائد الشرطه
الوطنيه عن تسعه من قيادات وزاره الداخليه
قضوا بالفعل في تحطوا هذه الطائره في
الحقيقه كانت الصور همم يعني تعبر عن حجم
الكارثه لان الطائره تحطمت في محيط روضه
للاطفال في تلك المنطقه في احدى ضواحي
ثياب السلطات تعمل لهناك منذ ساعات على
همم اطفاء الحريق وازاله الانقاذ طبعا
الاداره زكريا في كياب قالت بانها عاملت
على نقل الجميع الاطفال الذين كانوا خارج
الروضه همم يلعبون ويلهون في ساحه خارجيه
تم نقلهم لكن يعني تاكد ايضا وفقا لقائد
الشرطه الوطنيه بان عدد من هؤلاء الاطفال
اصيب بالفعل وان اثنين على الاقل من
الاطفال الذين كانوا في موقع الحادثه
قتلوا بالفعل اذا هذه حادثه همم جديده همم
قبل دقائق من الان تم تاكيدها وهي يعني
همم يعني جانب قد يكون من مرارات الحرب
المتواصله حتى وان كانت طائره هي طائره
اوكرانيه هذه
الطائرات طائره مروحيه اعلن عن تحطمها
فيها مسؤولون كبار من وزاره الداخليه على
راس الوزير نفسه الذي كما تؤكد الشرطه
لاوكرانيه قد قتل في في تحطم هذه الطائره
لكن طبعا السؤال البديهي الذي يطرح والذي
لا يمكن ربما الاجابه همم بعجله هو سبب
سقوط هذه الطائره هل في المعلومات التي
همم
ترددت هناك ما يشير الى ترجيح سبب معين
لتحطم هذه الطائره تامر
حتى هذه اللحظه حسن لا معلومات يعني
السلطات الاوكرانيه في كيابه الاداره
العسكريه لم تقدم مزيد من التفاصيل تقول
بان المعلومات شحيحه وشحيحه جدا حتى هذه
اللحظه لكن اسمح لي ان اتلو عليكم هذه
الاخبار التي تصل تباعا على الهاتف قائد
الاداره العسكريه يقول في كيف بالتاكيد في
العاصمه يقول وفقا للمعلومات الاوليه حتى
الان او هذا الخبر وصل للتو حتى الان همم
قتل سبعه عشر شخصا اذا يرتفع عدد هذه
الطائره الى 17 شخصا بينهم طفلان يعني
الحديث ايضا عن ان كل من في الطائره همم
ايضا بسبب تحطم هذه الطائره وسقوطها في
منطقه ماهوله بالسكان منطقه مدنيه بالقرب
همم
الاطفال يتحدث رئيس الاداره العسكريه
بالفعل الان يؤكد مره اخرى ويتحدث عن مقتل
طفلين يقول ان هناك اكثر من 22 شخصا في
المستشفيات في هذه الاثناء يتلقون العلاج
10 منهم هم من الاطفال اذا من الاطفال تلك
همم الروضه روضه الاطفال كما يقول في هذه
الاثناء احاول ايضا ان احصل على معلومات
اضافيه وانا اتحدث اليك واعود واقول بان
الصور التي ظهرت يعني كانت
تظهر دمار كبيرا في المحيط الذي تحطمت فيه
همم الطائره وهذا الدمار الكبير كما اشرت
اسفر عن همم هذا العدد من القتلى والجرحى
اذا نحن امام ماساه كبيره
سنعود اليك بطبيعه الحال توفر اي معلومات
جديده عن تحطم هذه الطائره وهمم ما اسفر
عنه بالتاكيد نواب ان ان يؤكد انه اعلنه
مدير الشرطه الاوكرانيه عن مقتل وزير
ومسؤولين كبار في الوزاره جراء تحطم هذه
المروحيه في همم كييف والذي اسفل عن سقوط
17 قتيلا في اخر تحديث للاحصائيه